shut up
shut up
she was saying yeah i play wrong but
yeah i did this yeah i did that blah
blah blah blah i'm building orphanages
i'll kick her in the pool
you're chatting [ __ ] brother
[Music]
beautiful people
everywhere everywhere when that song
came out bro everywhere i go
come on bro it was one of those ones
where
i think chris chris brown was going
through lacquer he was going from the
rmb hip-hop phase to like the dance
messy face yeah yeah what's he doing
yeah we're not we're all thinking what's
he actually doing are we sure are you
sure because um it was a consumer sure
what was it i want to say it was
probably the year before rihanna did a
few of them as well
i could she did the um
what is the rihanna banger bro
um the one with cal i want to say with
calvin harris is it with carbon
harassment maybe aura remembers the i'm
sure the video um
what's it called is that where are you
now or something like that yeah where
are you now yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
i'm sure
i'm sure it's calvin harris uh let me
check hold on
where have you been where have you been
where are you
where are you now is justin bieber i'm
pretty sure
yeah yeah where have you been bro where
have you been where have you been
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah she went off mm-hmm
yeah
where have you been bro
yeah like i want to say there's a year
or two before she starts having a few of
them
and then yeah when he went into that
thing i remember thinking what are you
doing and he did yeah yeah yeah do you
remember yeah yeah yeah
the video was slapping that one with the
rejects the rejects were in there t-pain
was in there was it there yeah yeah i
remember everyone was in there because
you've got one with t-pain in the studio
yes yes yes yes
yes yes um and then they're just gonna
run their scooters and just bump into
everyone from that yeah yeah that video
is sick yeah it made me like the song
even more he looks like he was having
fun it looked like he has the sickest
life yeah it does oh it did yeah yeah so
um that's a banger it was it was a
banger but anyway welcome people
hello happy
monday as always we're happy to see you
always
and um
before we go any further guys
we know you're craving some extra
content we get it all the time so what
you need to do is pause the video head
on over to patreon.com forward slash
shits and gigs and then you're gonna get
an extra episode every single thursday
okay we're doubling up two episodes a
week um come and enjoy enjoy every
episode we've ever shot on patreon yeah
man take the journey with us um you get
first dibs on the [ __ ] first dibs on
fan requests first dibs on x first dibs
on if you just want to have a chat
message us and we'll get back to you
faster than do anyone else okay so thank
you um patreon.com four assassins gigs
three pound a month
a day run the p you know the drill okay
um guys if you're watching on youtube do
some massive favor and
like
the video
give us the two fingers of death
ring that notification bell and
subscribe if you don't mind you'll be
doing us a massive favor if you're
listening on any form of audio platform
wherever you listen to your podcast just
give us a quick follow or a quick
subscribe write us a quick review uh
preferably five stars but we want you to
be open and honest if you think we suck
then tell us we suck um just so we can
do better but preferably five stars
we'll do fine i'd like to see you at
five yeah we'd prefer to see a five in
fact make it five
do us all a favor yeah yeah five say
what you want to say in the review but
just make sure the review says five
stars
so you need to stay with your chest
leave your email address if you want to
click back and forth yeah but make sure
it says five stars please
um we'll get back to you yeah we can't
lose this
we're we're too far deep okay we've quit
our jobs we've got nowhere else to go so
please don't damage our reputation
um
um on top of that guys
uh
well i don't even know what i was gonna
say oh on top of that fuegs is rocking
the
sng logo to cleanest character t it runs
off the shelves i'm rocking my pokemon
t-shirt i'll tell you what last time i
rocked this t-shirt
at about 3 000 [ __ ] messages people
asked me where i got this t-shirt yeah
and you know what at that time i was
happy to tell him but let me tell you
about what happened yeah let me tell you
about the truth what happens behind the
scenes
[Music]
if you had a big performance of the
company sells these t-shirts um i've got
a couple more t-shirts at home i'm still
going to buy a couple more t-shirts
maybe in a few hoodies okay i still like
this company i want to give them money
yeah we reached out to the company um
after i got all these messages i thought
you know what this is annoying me i'm
not going to reply to all these messages
all the time let me tell you what we i
reached out to the company i said guys
what's up uh gave us a little background
of what we do um i just told them bro i
keep getting messages non-stop all the
comments on my tick tock all the
comments on instagram keep asking
where's this t-shirt from um if you guys
want to come together on a little
sponsorship thing a little collapsing
let us know um
and we'll we'll be down to work with it
exactly
family came back to us in 10 minutes
said gang we're down that sounds sick
[ __ ] let's do it gas gas gas
specifics yeah let's just get the money
out of the way that's that's what's
going on that's what's going to cost you
uh we can do this and we can do this
we're flexible man like we want to work
with you guys here you go they came back
and said now we're in pain
i said hang on
what do you mean guys what you've got
all right now we don't do paintings
okay you're having your big time all
right
all right i said okay you know what
maybe this um how about you send us a
young affiliate link every time someone
sends me a message saying with a t-shirt
i can just send them straight to you
there you go just give me a little
something at the top let me if we had
our beak on this
whatever however many gums we we sell
for you
yeah we're losing
we don't want to make money off this
like we want to help you guys exactly
yeah we're not we're we're set
um
but let's wet our beaks a little bit
daddy's thirsty
[Laughter]
daddy's a little parched let me whip my
beak
that's hilarious just a little satin at
the top in it yeah yeah yeah just give
me the crumbs
but we'll send all the business your way
just give me the crumbs family came back
and still said nah
so they want they want us to promote
their [ __ ] but they don't want to pay us
for it so you know what
guys if you're thinking i want to ask
james where you got that t-shirt don't
bother bro cause i'm not telling you
and you know what on top of that i'm
gonna make my own pokemon t-shirt
and then i'm gonna shot them once so i'm
still gonna buy for this company but no
freak brandon i'm not telling anyone
where i'm going no free branding i'm not
anyone where i've got this t-shirt i'm
gonna rock it every week
i'm never gonna tell fam funny enough
you say that because obviously
i've got the dragon ball z one yeah yeah
can't find it i swear i was looking for
it um on monday just gone because i was
gonna wait to my staff do on top because
i wore i wore a tea and a raw shirt on
top you know i like that i like that
you like the layers i love the layers i
was thinking because i didn't know what
i was going to wear i was thinking i've
not worn that shirt in a while let me
wear that tee fam i removed my whole
wardrobe couldn't find it i don't know
where it is i don't know where it is and
i'm living i'm going to shut up
don't buy another one
i can't find my street fighter one i've
got a street fighter one from now i
can't find that either i just don't
understand because no one else wears
that teeth apart from me i don't know
where it is oh i couldn't find this one
for ages it's the first time i in time i
don't know where my [ __ ] goes man i
chucked it in the dryer by accident as
well it's tight tight now it's tight
tight now maybe because your boy's
leveling up yeah
he's been hitting the weight yeah i
don't want to blow my own trumpet yeah
yeah oh but um
yeah man yeah man yeah man but anyway
guys i'm not telling
week's fun fact is about the one and
only dwayne the rock johnson um
so dwayne the rock johnson is breaking
all the records with these new um booze
brand obviously we know terra mana
tequila we're big fans of tequila so you
know
patterns make sense so terraman has just
surpassed 600 000 the 600 000 case mark
a record for first year sales in
johnson's tequila pipeline
in johnson's tequila pipeline is a
worldwide expansion in a bid to take
over to take terramana global today
mexico and america and then tomorrow the
world to put in reference george
clooney's casa amigos which i didn't
even know was george clooney's
um tequila brand assaulted diagio for
one billion dollars oh my selling
approximately 170 000 cases and the rock
has sold 600 000 cases
first of all i didn't even know casa
amigos was george clooney's case is a
big boy tequila i knew george clooney
had a tequila i didn't know
i did
uh
is in almost every established
restaurant bar whatever swear period
almost almost
i've never
ever ever clocked that with george
clooney's and
[Music]
dirt caked and he's got that nest cafe
deal what's that one i've not seen that
one well he's in all the nescafe adverts
you never seen not anymore maybe i have
or had but not paying attention yet
there was a stint for a few years i
don't watch tv anymore so i don't know
true neither did i but um for a stint
years he was in nest k adverts all the
time so they must be paying him bags on
bags on bags on bags
just when he's got enough money
the rock has got enough money the rock's
got too much money like jesus have you
seen the under armour thing as well so
all the ufc fighters now we're under
armour creps on the weigh-in and weight
and all that stuff anything press
conference wise they're all we're under
armour
bro he's doing too much
didn't know that he's doing too much
he's getting so much money for no reason
if i was going to say unless he's going
to run for president i don't know what
more what does he want we've literally
had this conversation three or four
times now he's he has to run for
governor saying he has to do an arnold
schwarzenegger yeah because yeah there's
nothing else he can do he's got it all
he's got everything he's done the movies
he's done the um [ __ ] wrestling he's
done
car not cause he's done tequila he's
done every [ __ ] avenue that he wants
to do and he's just blowing it and
blowing it and blowing it and blowing it
and blowing i don't understand what more
challenges six hundred thousand six
hundred thousand cases in the first year
wow that's a lot six hundred thousand i
would buy a case as well i kept saying
to you i want to get something because
i'm never saying that since there are
launched yeah it's impossible to get
your hands on
to be fair now i know they don't even
sell it here so that's probably why i
can't get your [ __ ] hands on it but
still
[ __ ] the bed bro
bro he's [ __ ]
i would love
i would love to see the rock's bank
account
i wouldn't
that's the last place i want to look it
would depress you oh 100 i don't think
it would depress it would
i don't think it would depress me i
would want to know
if everything i see of the rock ie on
the socials actually weighs up to his
account oh it does oh we think slash no
it does but i want to know oh you know i
know it does
i wouldn't know him and him and
obviously um kevin hart yeah them two i
would just love to say bank accounts um
i was gonna say as well like
this is an interesting thing as well
like
in terms of money like
do you ever think like how much just a
million is
yes and no because
i was
i can't remember what was which show was
i watching
i think i was watching a show
because someone else was watching a show
and i was just watching them watching it
kind of thing you know so i was it
wasn't the show i was watching it was
something that someone else put on so i
was watching it now and i think they had
something to do with stealing cash
and
they were wrapping up in bundles and
each bundle was a was ten bags
and i think they just put two bags
together two bundles together and they
were like this could pay off this this
this this this and it was one of those
ones where
those three bundles show you what you
can make in the what you make in a year
or two yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah is
that it
is that's it fam well if you think about
it this way
um
if you made if you make 10 grand a month
that's healthy of course you make 10
grand a month it's only 120 grand a year
you're saying only like it's obvious
to a millionaire that's what i'm saying
oh wow yeah that's what i said it's like
you ever think how much a million is
yeah yeah yeah yeah if you make 10 grand
a month yeah you're in the top
top one percent of this country bro like
probably top 0.1 if you're making 10
bags a month
10 bags a month you're only 120 grand a
year
[ __ ] imagine how much you need to make a
million bro
a million a year a million pounds
dollars whatever
no i i don't think i can visualize what
a million looked like you'd have to be
on 10 bags a month for the best part of
a decade
and not spend a penny to get to a
million
yo it means you're rich for nearly 10
years before you even get 1 million whoa
yeah man that's that's
that's actually a mind [ __ ] and you want
to look in the rocks account
not me bro not me
not me brother i still would i still
would want to
because i i i don't know man i don't
know it's unfathomable money which is
which is why i don't see why he needs to
keep going yeah but some people just
need it some people can't sleep at night
unless they've got something that
they're just yeah
i would understand that because we've
had this discussion before i would
understand that if like he didn't have a
wife he didn't have kids enough any of
this so he all he's doing is chasing the
bag he's got a family bro bro i know how
does he make time for this some people
he don't sleep in it some people
convince himself of whatever in it but
it's all about like
i think it would have you'd have to take
a conversation with him personally and
he would have to probably flip it back
on you okay or on us okay and then you
if you if you actually got to sit him
down in black bro no offense like you've
got this going on you've got your own
production company you got this you got
that you got this you got that like [ __ ]
i forgot yeah as well she's got [ __ ]
energy drinks yeah you've got a [ __ ]
tequila like you've got everything bro
like why why do you keep going and i
feel like all it would have to take is
him being like what else would you have
me do
what else would you have me do
like what else am i supposed to do apart
from keep chasing it what else would you
have me do to be fair you say like oh
you've got kids like sit home with your
kids and wife is that a joke
so instead of conquering the world you
want me to sit at home with my kids and
wife they're not really
it doesn't weigh up yeah they're not
really it doesn't well yeah guys we're
going to take a quick break real quick
to shed some love on the boys over at
manscaped you know the vibes so we're
chilling smooth into january now the new
year's fully set in everyone's back on
their their their gym vibes getting a
little bit sway
get a little bit sticky
but yeah we need to take the look a bit
wham
a lord of the ring shoulders and now
and um
but yeah you need to start the new year
off with a fresh [ __ ] of
[ __ ] a fresh set of testies as well and
you want to send your thanks over to
landscapes okay so along with the
um
performance package no well including
the formless package 4.0 you've got the
lawnmower 4.0 we've been through that
you've got the led light this is this is
in
it comes with their skin safe technology
which means no mixing no nooks no
crannies no nicks waterproof waterproof
as well and in there we've said it
before okay you've got the crop
preserver
okay
you've got anti-chafing bull deodorant
and anti-chafing
including there you get the fresh
leather shed travel bag that comes in
there it comes with full instructions
okay it comes with everything you need
even comes if maybe if you don't want to
go skin to skin you got the little
adapters on the trimmer as well it comes
with a little magazine as well it comes
with a little magazine newspaper type
thing it's a whole experience experience
when they send you your performance
package it's a whole experience and the
experience goes on and on and on the
battery life on these things is out of
control i've charged mine
once this year so far really yeah yeah
i'd use it on a regular fair i've
charged it all once bro fair play um
so guys if you want to jump on board you
already know what to do you need to head
on over to manscape.com the code is sng
and that's going to get you 20 off and
free shipping so manscape.com sng sierra
november golf
20 off free shipping worldwide without
any further ado let's get back to the
episode thank you very much
and props to him though because to my
knowledge in our era our decade he paved
the way for wrestlers to become actors i
don't know big boy
i don't know anyone else really outside
of him that was the pioneer for
wrestling from wrestling to acting in my
opinion so i know like hulk hogan's done
little bits
i think hulk hogan was the first
wrestling superstar oh fish transition
to like mainstream anywhere everyone
knows who hulk hogan is whether you're a
wrestling fan or not yeah yeah volkhog
and rick flair yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
i've got a tweet about rick flair remind
me later all right calm um
i think hulk yeah i reckon hulk hogan's
the first global superstar to come out
wrestling to my knowledge obviously
you've got stuff like andre did the
giant mm-hmm but he's like i think he
was like 80s
yeah yeah 80s and stuff like yeah hulk
hogan i think rick obviously i just said
rick flair um
but in terms of the consistency and the
mainstream
the rock was there or the rock is there
rather i remember um stone cold doing a
few triple triple h did a few obviously
um
baptista now is this i would say like
the second biggest what about wrestler
actor
[ __ ] what's his face who big show no
no no no no no um
oh my god bro describe him i can't i
hate how my he's he's more famous than
he's it's a rock than him it's um in
wrestling world from wrestling to acting
it's um
he speaks chinese he speaks chinese yeah
he came out recently they speak chinese
he's in train wreck
um he's in um he's in everything bro
like uh he speaks chinese you speak
chinese but he's reached like is he fro
is he english is he american sorry of
course he's american yeah he's a
wrestler um bro everyone scream must be
screaming the tv right now it's [ __ ]
um
oh
chinese
white black white
bro you're gonna
john cena bro john [ __ ] he speaks
chinese freaks mandarin yeah
[ __ ] yeah bro johnson can speak mandarin
[ __ ]
yeah fair play
yeah yeah yeah john cena can't see me
famous famous i forgot about him he's an
actor wow i forgot about john cena wow
yeah yeah yeah very true very cheerful
he's so jacked bro stupid jacked he's so
jacked she doesn't make sense super
jacked super jacked
i forgot about john cena wow he's in
stuff but he's nowhere near on the level
as well
the rock does two three movies a year
yeah he's streaming a year
he's already got a movie coming out this
christmas with um brother daddy captain
america what's his name
chris chris evans evans he's already got
me it came out the other day saying that
dc and marvel are collaborating to do a
christmas movie buffs he's not dc and
marvelous just because dc and marvel
abbey is not christmas it's not i know i
know i know because i think i saw the
headline myself but what a joke thing is
something stupid
oh the rock who's not even made his
movie yet and chris evans who's no
longer with marvel uh so the rock and
chris evans they've got nothing to do
with eva
and now doing a christmas movie why are
you celebrating i hate
i really hate that because they couldn't
be so separate from those brands but you
need those brands to bring that together
why can't you just say chris and chris
um
the rock and chris evans are doing a
christmas movie i'm interested yeah i'm
i'm probably not gonna watch it yeah but
i'm intrigued oh okay cool if i was into
christmas movies and i'm like gang yeah
this christmas has been apart
this christmas is like yeah lethal
weapons out yeah this is in home alone
out this is in harry potter's out this
is it yeah but i don't need to hear dc
and marvel bro because then i'm thinking
superheroes yeah yeah yeah
and that's not what you're gonna bring
to me
fast [ __ ] just gonna be disappointed
yeah yeah that's [ __ ] pissed me off
yeah that adam hasn't even come out yet
when it's out it's out this year no this
is summer i believe
i believe no idea i don't even seen a
proper trailer yet i've only seen i
think it's the one i put in the group
chat yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah that wasn't even a
better trailer there was more the rock
just chatting about it yeah i wasn't
even a [ __ ] trainer that was a rock
chat
um anyway i'm interesting to see that
movie though yeah i'm very intrigued to
see that movie i am um
cool so fam i needed to ask you i hope
you say yes
have you started ozark no i haven't i
haven't you had
i haven't they keep the fire coming i
haven't i'm jealous i haven't i'm like
four episodes in
i'm gonna watch it i've had a busy week
i've had a busy week i believe you g i
suppose i i will watch it i binged
um do you remember when i said to you
the other day um on tuesday that was it
on tuesday when i said like you know
when you've got so much to do
that you don't know where to start so
you do nothing yeah so you sat there
watching those so i watched three
episodes back to back of ozark yeah oh
it was fantastic i'm jealous bro four
episodes in it's fantastic jealous bro
you remember you know the old school
justin timberlake n sync justin
timberlake like it's gotta be me times
where you have the curly hair someone
put a picture of him and saying
i'm gonna say that this was ruth from
ozark
[Music]
[Laughter]
when i saw that picture i died wrong oh
that's jokes because you can see the
hair i'm talking about yeah then
whispers bits bro that's hilarious that
genuinely looks yeah they're going to
tell my kids this is ruth from ozark oh
that's jokes bro but yeah from there
there's a whole i don't know how they
keep the fire coming neither do i bro
but there's a whole new development
really implemented one character
who's [ __ ] up everything for everyone
like in season three like um
ben yeah what's his name ben uh the
brother yeah bendy yeah yeah yeah yeah
come on i found wendy
someone needs to stop her oh really i
remember saying this in season two i do
remember so you're saying that i hate it
during season two
then season three we had the brother
sister connection so i felt a bit bad
yeah and then she did turn into a [ __ ]
and again fam she's gone off the rails
really in this season she's she's gone
off the rails bro
because back in season two she was
trying to snake marty more wasn't she
she was trying to like get on top of my
kind of thing and then season three he
squashed that he squashed it on the on
the spot he let her know that like you
don't know who i am you actually don't
you don't know who i am you don't know
what i can bring to the these man need
me they don't need you brother they like
you they don't need
i remember how season three
ended when they both went back to
i think was it mexico when they went to
and that lady came out the car just back
helen got popped they one bang there and
they had and i was like my jaw dropped
bro because she i didn't know how they
were gonna get rid of helen because she
was commanded and demanded everything
fam everything fam
she was calling shots got ben put in
back in the hospital she was calling
shots i was like how are they going to
get rid of her
firm she was calling shots the end
season bang popped her the jaw dropped
bro
fam to be fair we should say spoiler
alert but that's like a year ago that
was the year
yeah have you ever seen your problem
i'm sorry
phone this season wendy's off the rails
i can't wait wendy's off the roads and
there's a new character in there who's
[ __ ] up everything i can't wait
he's [ __ ] blocking everything can't wait
yeah yeah yeah um he's so he's like i
can take it without supporting it he's
like a member of the so obviously
like he's a member of the cartel family
okay he's a member of the cartel family
okay he's now implemented into the
current affairs okay
i'm looking forward to it he plays by
his own rules
he plays by his own rules they have to
all right mike's stressed out
i think that's the only way they can
keep this [ __ ] going because last season
it was all about ben's situation [ __ ]
[ __ ] up yeah you have to keep
implementing new people too that's the
thing as well like with that kind of
stuff like it seemed like ben
i like what i like about is that ben was
a very unique twist that you didn't know
was going to have that much impact on
how everything goes of course and then
once that kind of ran its course it's
kind of like you can't do that again
though
and they haven't done it but they have
but they haven't and it's completely
different and you're like oh okay they
start napkins season four okay bro i'm
looking forward to it bro bro i'm
looking [ __ ] forwards i love ozark oh
ozark's the best i love ozark netflix
come with fire no
they know what they're doing roblox come
with fire now they're doing wrong they
do know what they're doing speaking of
hippies speaking of netflix speaking of
fire
speaking of netflix speaking of fire hit
me t-h-t-h c-h-t-h thuther the t-wat to
handle too hot to handle season three
i'll be honest with you i haven't seen
season one i haven't seen season two
i've the thing is i saw season one when
it first dropped which i think was
i want to say two three years because i
was in my old yard i never saw season
two saw season one and then i've seen
season three bro i remember season one
because i'm every everyone on socials
were saying is much better than uh love
island really everyone was comparing it
too i've seen love island though as well
everyone was comparing it to love and i
think at that year
i had watched for the first time that
season of love island oh okay and thch
came out after love island
did you think it was better i think in
terms of the
extremities of what they have to do in
thch it makes it better than love island
okay cool does that make sense yeah yeah
so that's the only reason why i say thj
is better than love what i do like about
love about thch is that they use people
from everywhere in the world whereas oh
hi fam i love that they use everyone in
the world as opposed to their hair they
love island yeah it's just americans or
english people yeah yeah everything they
have their own like wherever they're at
fam
thch this season obviously i've never
seen any other season this season
this season
you feel connected to the
representatives of this country
when the representatives of the uk come
into that show you're like please be
buff a lie please baby buff and please
talk of sense fam
please don't be an idiot like you're
you're representing england here brings
you [ __ ] flying the flag my dog
the whole concept was juicy
the whole concept was juicy in terms of
like
um
the whole concept was juicy in terms of
just like for one where everyone's from
the in the world
and that that coming together and it
brings like a next kind of spice like
knowing nathan was south african was
interested yeah very very interesting i
love the south african twang anyway yeah
so for those who actually don't even
know what to handle is or the premise or
anything because obviously i was
comparing it to love island
it's a um it's a basically a
quote-unquote date and love show um
there's 10 10 to 12 contestants i think
they they replenish people all the time
there's a prize fund of this time was
200 bags when i watched it the first
thing was only 100 yeah they said they
doubled out they doubled up so it's 200
000
um but the the clause is you can't kiss
you can't have sex no heavy petting and
you can't have any self gratification
every time you break a rule they deduct
money off
they deduct money from the total part
and these men were breaking rules cuz
they couldn't help themselves they were
breaking rules
they couldn't help themselves that first
week rules after breaking they didn't
care rules have to break bro that first
night fam bro have to they didn't care
have to
have to do you know who i thought was
slick and fell from grace
let me guess let me guess let me guess
let me guess
not nathan
um i want to say
either steven
or
who else was in from the jump
maybe truth true truth
true truth was up he fell from voice he
left he came with two left for none
came with two left wings up up he slips
the biggest
i think
my biggest pet peeve ick from truth was
when he said truth wasn't his real name
fam
when i found out truth was not his real
name and the truth was a lie
i was done with him his name's robert or
something
i can't i have to find it because when i
found that out i had to like yo i had to
mention it i had to mention it his name
is robert you got it [ __ ] robert
[ __ ] robert i couldn't believe he
switched up to truth and he said
because he plays ball as well yeah
baseball says that if i'm playing ball
i've probably got a girl there's
watching me i've probably got a girl
there
just spin the ball oh smack out
i don't know
if you're in truth shoes how would you
have patterned the situation with izzy
and jazz
i would have been open because at that
time
well to be fair it went from because
when he when he was patterning both of
them from the start
they still thought it was a pleasure
thing yes
so when he passed both of them initially
yes pleasure ting yes then when it was a
thch team
it got to um that's when it had to be a
little bit more involved and that's
where he fell off he didn't know how to
do juggle yeah he couldn't juggle when
it was all a pleasure thing i feel like
he was more open to being like it's
whatever it is i'm escaping you're fine
you're fine like i'm a sketcher
we're all here to be scared but when it
was like a you need to pick one thing
he had rookie moves on him
he had the rookies he had no game zero
game i was thinking this guy can't lie
or cheat worth a damn bro like a man
said
oh actually you know what's funny
actually i'm just gonna pause to it so
obviously we've got a list of x for
these things yes before i get into this
yes i want to make sure truth is not in
my list of x okay because i don't i want
to talk about it and then go through the
list of okay okay i don't want to start
freeing up my x for truth okay he's not
in my list of x i've got one ick for
truth on my load all right cool just one
fam this is not yeah this is not my list
of eggs
when my man got caught out in the
bedroom
the morning of yes
and man said
i didn't lie i didn't lie i didn't lie
to both of them and both of them like
are you are you [ __ ] smart
[Music]
both of them are just are you
gum figures in it are you [ __ ] stupid
brother
are you thick are you telling me to my
face you didn't lie big man tell me what
you said then because i just told you
what you said he fumbled the whole back
and i said i never lied to anybody i
never lied to you i never lied to you i
told you both the truth i never said i
was done with jazz yes you did big man
that's word for word what you said you
said you told jazz you were done with
her and you're checking for me i'm
checking for izzy and jess is telling me
you told her the exact opposite bro and
now you're still saying you're never lie
never lied man when he was talking to
izzy and you know that those four stones
before they get to the room in the pool
man
he said [ __ ] jazz dash to drink
i told jazz i want you
and she is he said to him are you trying
[ __ ]
man grab the waist pull the clothes
lipstick
lipstick you could have say a word when
he lost both of them i've never seen a
man look so destroyed from great he
looked like he lost 10 pounds the next
day his eyes were blooded and red
he looked like he didn't sleep the whole
time
he couldn't he was shaking he went from
a buff brother he was lip-syncing as
soon as he lost both his yachts
he looked like a different guy
it was the funniest that was the
earliest funniest moment of the thing
i couldn't believe what i've seen
i couldn't believe what i'd seen i've
never seen a man react like that oh
[ __ ] lost his hose and was just like
i don't know what to do
and i don't
that's only two you know he had no
interest of anyone else coming in was he
there he that's the thing because he
didn't even see brianna no he would have
moved
and he would have moved to her bro i
think because i think after i binged the
show i went on there um
on thj's instagram and i think i looked
at the story and he was on their story
and someone had asked him if
he was on the show when briana was there
would you have moved he was like
100. her and nathan when they went to
the date when i was thinking nathan's
finna cheat
fam nathan's gonna lose some money today
today man said you've got the fattest
ass in it fat sauce in the village i
know i know she said guys love a pretty
face and i'm a fat ass
[Laughter]
when i heard that i was thinking i'm
cheating
i'm cheating when my man
when she asked him is your head turned
in i said no
he came back and then
i know what i'm going to tell holly how
it is i'm just going to tell her how it
is i'm going to tell her what happened
i'm telling you guys
tell her how i feel
she says so what is it did your head
turn my surgeon no no it's not even have
it started she's like obviously we got
there there was chocolate she was like
shut up and tell me what happened man
was trying to elongate the whole i mean
he was his mind was doing backflips
you know
you know
um have you seen the simpsons in that
you know that toy monkey that claps the
the things like that it's just like that
that was in his head that there he was
shaking fast so he was shaking he had
all the confidence before they sat down
before i'm just gonna tell the whole
story so she understands where i'm
coming from you know this romance thing
like that
she needs holly needs to understand that
these men are setting me up for failures
these men are setting me up so i need to
produce them chocolate fondue there was
marshmallows there was oil there was
candles there was all sorts of oh my god
never choice fam he got halfway through
the sense she just shut up shut up and
tell me what happened
i'm in his shoes
he stumbled and was like
yeah
she said did your head turn or not fam
man said
no
no no no no no you know what it didn't
you know it just made me realize i'm
only for you and then i went back my
story to the interview room said for the
love of god
they need to not find out
i pray they don't find out
he could just when they were in the when
they were in the bedroom or waiting for
brian has come back brianna to come back
into the room
that night
fam he's either peeled at the door fam
every time the door open when the door
closed by itself his heart was shook
i couldn't be any shoes i couldn't i
couldn't be naked i couldn't i couldn't
i couldn't i couldn't i couldn't oh he
went through it he was tested he went
through it
he was tested to the limit oh my god
when brianna was like i wouldn't be me
if i didn't shoot my shot nathan what
are you saying that's juicy i said well
i can't just say no to the date can i
eat
she put on a spike
that's again what you could say mom was
sat there like this in his nice white
shirt i'm dressed up now i'm just
exactly saying i can't say no i've
already put the shirt on the shirt comes
on it doesn't come off i'm just going to
see what she's saying she seems like a
lovely girl you know i'm just getting
friendly i'm obviously going to be a
gentleman yeah i'm not gonna pay i
wasn't gonna be a gentleman so i'm gonna
act like i'm on a date because i'm on a
date
[ __ ] holly was having none of it none
bro zero zero she i've never seen
someone so shook in her life
she said my heart is in his hands it had
been what four days yeah four episodes i
don't know how at that point she needs
to relax yeah yeah she needs to check
herself she needs to relax
she needs to have a dip in a pool or
side yeah
her head wasn't working when they
isolate these man they don't think
straight
they isolate you when they isolate these
men on the island they can't think true
all they know is their bubble fountain
that's the thing with holiday romances
holiday romances is someone needs to do
a clinical trial on holiday romances
because i've in my life even when i was
a kid there's times where like
i would go out like my parents would
take me to like a holiday camp like
there's one time we went snowboarding
when we were kids
there was fam there's one time we went
to snowboarding when we were kids there
was one girl she looked like a year i
can't remember how old she was i think
she was like a year older to me than me
okay i was in love with this hoe
after two days
after two days i would have cut my wrist
for this time i was in love but there
was no one else on the planet bro when
you're in this isolation team yeah
you're in a different country
i was in love with this yeah same thing
happened when i went to a different
holiday ah i can't remember what it was
there was a different holiday i went on
same thing like a um just like a holiday
camp kind of thing when there's bad
people fam there was one yeah and i was
in love with this [ __ ]
because there's no one else and you
can't go anywhere else of course they're
all you have to look forward to seeing
because it's just you and your [ __ ]
family of course and then this
[Music]
[ __ ] painting know exactly what you
mean man i know exactly i've never been
through that i don't think to my to my
knowledge but i can fully understand how
it works man yeah bro so yeah when they
isolate this man they latch on to
someone
[ __ ] you know fam they latch on to
someone do you know who the funniest
brain in that show was not a trick
i've got x from patrick
james i've got x for patrick james
patrick i'm so happy they put him in
that show because
without him
i don't necessarily think i would have
been able to
enjoy the what's the word i'm looking
for the um
[ __ ] there's always something stupid
there's always someone that makes you
cringe makes you do this the comic
relief he was a comic relief
it was him but he he flipped it on us
from when he said i'm leaving everyone
was balling
balling never seen anything like it
georgia couldn't breathe
when patrick said i'm out stuff
okay let's start into the x because i
can't avoid them anymore okay first ick
steven can't stop crying he can't he
cries for every given scenario any
opportunity he gets bam and he says he's
a bad boy seven km in a ting like i'm a
bad boy i do this
i do this i do that i do this fam
any chance he can cry he'll cry ball his
eyes out he's always balling his face is
red all the time every time he looks up
he'll always go like this and look up
his eyes are blood red
he's always balling bro did it make
sense man it didn't make sense how many
times he was crying like you said
georgia was losing breath when he left
when patrick left
crying her eyes out found her eyes out
after man sang for her with the fam all
right let me go through my eggs
all right we'll go one for one i've got
let me see i've got one two three four
five six
seven i've got seven x just for patrick
in general no in general i've got about
20. all right cool say less then i
really already said one choose your name
being robert and then he spins the ball
that's one egg done there done dusted
you said
yeah true's name being robert is the
fattest kick i've ever heard in my life
you're ashamed of yourself which makes
me ashamed of you
yo fam that's too funny spencer said how
can i respect you when you don't respect
yourself
how can i respect you there you go
truth was a joke artist truth was a joke
he thought he would clean up fam when i
saw him first rocking that i thought he
would clean up as well
and he did he did on the first day he
did and then he just lacked experience
that's the word he lacked experience he
didn't have it in his repertoire he
didn't have his locker he thought he was
named that was a learning thought he was
nathan he didn't oh
nathan was losing bags on bags on bags
on bags
and yet made it to the end of the show
and then made it top three couldn't
believe it what what a plot twist i
would have kicked up a ruckus as soon as
they called his name when he stood up i
knew they were gonna call nathan they
gave him chance after chance he was the
golden child of that show they gave him
chance after chance after chance [ __ ] it
up and he abused their trust so many
times and then let him go into the
finals every time he dipped up for the
date seeing a biddy yeah see the bitty
funny oh right um hit me
oh fam this is a very very subtle ick
okay episode one yeah very soft like you
don't even probably don't even remember
do you remember when um
patrick gave holly the flower yes of
course but then he was vex because he
clocked the georgia's the painting yes
and he's thinking bruv she's gonna think
that i want holly
so you want to give georgia a flower
from when he first walks in that room to
give her a flower
let's say the door's here yeah and the
bed's 10 meters over there okay fam he
walks in
in silence she sees him she's the only
one in the bedroom she sees him walk in
he walks in opens the door walks in
doesn't say nothing yeah and just walks
to the bed
i'm i'm sweating to god it's like four
seconds of silence with them just locked
eyes yeah and then he gets to the point
goes
hi
like say
like say he just opened the door yeah
fam walked in made eye contact walked
all the way over
hi
patrick every time he laughed he was
like
the top
every time patrick laughed
it was
it was unbearable it was unbearable
unbearable i couldn't believe every time
he laughed he stuck his tongue out like
that bro
bro
patrick
patrick
bro his whole his whole
intro real was so cringe
so cringe bro everything he did was just
so cringe singing with the guitar bro my
first three eggs are patrick bro patrick
patrick patrick patrick i've got bear
patch i've got three actually let me run
through my first patrick's go for it
let's just get patrick out that way yes
and we can actually establish what we're
trying to do here shout out to you
patrick you say yo raise the patrick you
made the show the show
i will say one thing before i ruin his
life
patrick's the unsung hero of that show
100 because like i said he was a joke
yeah for the first three episodes and
then there was like three more episodes
where it was kind of like why is he even
here no reason but then he kept
bringing just like he was getting all
the guys meditating
he kept saying [ __ ] and every time like
he'd say stuff everyone just shut up
yeah people listen to him
yeah yeah yeah left with his health with
his head held high family rate
oh my god this is the most ickiest bit
do you remember when um before they
realized it was too hot to handle yes
and they were doing this lipstick
challenge
so the girl would block the xbox i've
got that in my notes brother x master
spot
georgia gets up
georgia gets up every man's on their
toes tippy mom she does the eggs i think
she doesn't have that's here and two and
a half yeah yeah harry stood up fam flew
up patrick
this is frederick hang on
georgia xxx harry did it
patrick
man man sat down like this
he sounded like this not only did he
wait for harry to go he waited for
stefan to go and then patrick went last
i couldn't believe it bro
shameful behavior
i'm telling you now
i'm not sitting down
if i've stood up regardless of
i'm going up there and i'm staring over
each other
i'm gonna be here yeah while they're
lip-syncing hurry up it's my turn hurry
up because she's the penguin on this
island i need her to know i'm about
about it i'm barry barragey harry hurry
up
you've been moving like a [ __ ] all
afternoon hurry up
you don't want to be in this race hurry
up
van patrick stood up
he he went forward and back sat down and
went like this
you got served
it literally it was a remember was it
step up two
in the rain
remember
patrick
hey
that's patrick
stop it stop it
you look so lovely in that dress by the
way blah blah blah blah would you
remember
you trying to make my balls blue
and he told he said he loves her and i
love you he locked off the thing with
and i love you george was that
her mouth fumbled i met you six hours
ago listen to me cuz i make you sick at
fam he has no game he has no game no
vocals the man can't string together a
rhyme
i just i just don't understand
how
he thought his hawaiian charm would work
because he's clearly just been in hawaii
and it works for him there you know you
thought he could bring that overseas
yeah
and turks and cake because i'm assuming
turks and caicos ain't that far from
hawaii it's like a young hop skip and
jump island-wise and he just adjusted
and patented did not pattern in the
slightest bro his
his serenading abilities are a joke i
think that was his only lips in the
whole show
the the third the x-master supposed to
mark the spot kissing georgia yeah yeah
it was time yeah he didn't lose nothing
else
nah man
nah man i couldn't go on that kind of
show and just lips one gal on the first
episode and i'm in there for the
majority of the show
get me off yeah 100 i'm talking to the
bruiser get me off what's the point
what's the entertainment value get me
off
do you know what i mean bam
as soon as georgia dumped me like that
no i'm i'm i'm i'm i'm looking at the
cameraman dead in his eye
on some from the seating i'll look at
the cameraman and say fam wrap it up
i'll take off my thing like this and
take off my thing like this
fanny pack thing i'm clipping it i'll
let it hit the floor
i'll walk i'm just getting the
microphone hit the thing
your head is boom and you're just you
know when the camera drops to the side
and you can just see the footsteps all
these possess me
get me off you'll just hear me echoing
in the back get me off
get me your faint echo
back off get me off
and you can see the producers running
onto the thing with their proper shoes
on and my bare foot and i'm like nah nah
i'm not gonna [ __ ] sit here and be
taking for a [ __ ] mug on netflix buff
get me off get me off the show
what are you playing that get me off the
show oh dave that's hilarious he didn't
even attempt from when olga rocked up he
didn't even attempt it when brianna
walked up he didn't even attempt it when
olga walked up and she said i love
patrick's body
i don't remember her saying that firm
she said oh because she made her ideal
man yeah his body nathan's head
something like nathan's height something
i remember yeah
and as soon as i find out steven lipster
after that
i'm off oh but do you know the thing
about steven obviously
when
before he started serenading before
patrick started serenading georgia and
they were having a conversation before
he brought the guitar and he said oh
you've got [ __ ] fantastic eyes like
it's green with a little bit of red with
a little bit of this do you know what i
mean
stole the tank stole
do you know the gang thing about um that
that bar your eyes are red or whatever
whatever i went on um
george's because i remember i told you i
went on twitter's instagram that went
through quite a few of them then it went
on george's instagram her
status is what patrick said about the
eyes i've got my phone somewhere
it says
green with a splash of red or some [ __ ]
so george blah blah underneath says i
got those green eyes with a bit with a
little bit of red tint and some brown in
there with the pre eyes so she just left
it there bros i was like patrick patrick
that's gang even though you got zero
[ __ ] you've left the mark sam you've
clearly left the mark so well played 100
player magic well played run me i've got
let's move on to stefan next thing
because i've got one seven i've got two
seven eight um
stefan steel in the um i move and i
think i don't
yes i do have another one
when he said to georgia
when he said to jo when he when they
were having a conversation and he was
like
go on i don't want i don't want to see
anyone else and i want you to be seen
with anyone when i see you with other
people gets me here everything's there
it's day two
it's day two
and you men are saying i don't want to
see you with anyone else this that any
other brother
nah man
i told you that when these men are
isolated they don't think
they don't understand demeanor like they
don't understand anything ethics nothing
fam that
that was mine but mine was the next
morning when when everyone has to fess
up as to why
and stefan said you know what brav
i just needed georgia to know that i'm
only about her i only think about her i
just want her brother she needed to know
how i feel about her brother
her face yeah yeah
what are you all about going on
what i only like you because you got
this bad boy thing you're out here
barley in front of everyone sending my i
don't want george
i make you yesterday fellas
i met you yesterday bro these men
actually knew the kind of man georgia
wanted
they wouldn't have tried this hard they
would have just been themselves and they
would have banged fam which rolls onto
harry big man
south african red south african brother
from joburg it's joe yeah
he's cleaning up brother and then george
is there shaking when she saw him i'm
freaking let's go harry george is
finally going to get what she came here
for oh she's going to bags she will cost
back yeah she make it worth it fam fam
fam she's gas stuffing gas stuffing
gasoline man said
i just want to let you know bro i want
like four kids kids i'm ready
this was the first night yes brother his
first night
what's going on who's feeding him these
lies she obviously
in my opinion she was the penguins want
to show her and piano
in the show
but it must she must look different in
3d
because these men were professing their
love for her it doesn't make any sense i
couldn't believe these men would drop
all the balls just to talk to her bro it
didn't make anything didn't make sense
but they lacked composure they liked
everything everything they did
he dropped it bro i want four kids you
know i love kids and she was like yeah
but you know i just met i was like yeah
yeah i know i know i know i don't wanna
know about i'm just just letting you
know
don't let me know and he was spitting
game in the in the one-on-one with the
camera saying i know what women like you
know i've got the game i know i'm gonna
say blah blah blah where did he find
these brothers bob
i was so upset
because i was thinking george has been
craving she has she's been craving to
just get anywhere
she she needs her vision of a nathan she
does she went in there looking for her
version of nathan do you know why i
think the thing is because clearly
everyone thought and assumed that she
was the pegasus one in the show she was
paying um because she gave me manga
robbie vice by the way hmm when she
smiles fam she gives me margaritas i
kind of see it now that you say it um
but what i was going to say is i think
there's a complex of because
sh the mandem assume and think she's the
penguin in the show
they have to act differently that's why
and not be themselves and not be like
this player or yeah because they think
that's not going to work it's not going
to work but she's seen that she's been
there she's done that but all she wanted
was a [ __ ] boy that's all she wanted it
was a fat boy all she wanted was a [ __ ]
bruh and if you had stayed true to
yourself i couldn't believe how much
they fumbled that bag bro i couldn't
believe how much they fumbled that bag
all three of them there's no
what is it it was harry at first
steven harry didn't know what to do
harry
harry reminds me of
harry reminds me of one of the those
kind of people where let's see all of us
in a click right we've all got yellow or
we're all dancing we're going to show
you we've all got girl dancing and he's
just there
and he's like [ __ ] i've not got a girl
i've not got again
and we try and like uh go with this he's
just happy with anyone yeah he's just
happy with that he just happened to be
part of the party you know he's happy to
get white yeah yeah yeah
if harry secures a wine gasps he's got a
wig that's for him
he's one of the dead ones we're asked
for him
that's the kind of that's the kind of
attitude i i i associate harry energy
boy that's harry's energy oh it was too
harry because as well obviously he's
english he was from middlesbrough the
way he spoke just made me laugh right
he's demeanor everything made me laugh
bro
is
harry
as patrick was the unsung hero
as patrick transitioned from being the
joke to the leader yeah harry just fell
into the joke role yep yeah yeah yeah
he fell into that joke mentally
caught wanking in the shower
he was mortar fight
when he had to we had a fiat obviously
let everyone know what happened in the
morning yes confessed him when he was on
the bed like this he was like this
funniest bit was when bo said
i know harry and i have nothing to fear
we're calm where can't we come and he
was like this
ah i pledged myself in the bathroom
everyone was like what that was like
what did what she would i've never heard
someone be so disappointed
harry was hilarious in that show he was
fast he's so fun he loves
he you can tell he loves to love oh he
does he loves too much he loves it he
loves it he loves it so much he fears
heartbreak
so we stuck in limbo
i was shook asking to be the girl he was
the whole girlfriend thing gave me a
kick as well
i'm going to ask you the question do you
want to be my girlfriend should i oh my
god yes she's like what am i going to
tell my mum what am i going to tell my
dad that whole thing it's me listen to
me now you're so jarring if i'm hurry
if i'm harry and i said oh
would you be my girlfriend yeah
and she said yes as soon as 10 seconds
later
she's like i can't believe i've got a
fella you haven't
you really have no you haven't you had
one for nine seconds and you [ __ ]
[ __ ] out bottled it
i can't believe it i can't believe
you've got a fella you don't you're
talking as if you've been juggling man
big man it's just me and you i can't
believe i've got filler what do you want
about it's been me and you first of all
how old are you are you 15. true fam run
me your driver's
license i do say i need something
stop stop stop stop because you're
trying to get a mortgage buff stop
harry was in love he wasn't like he
didn't care what she had to say he was
so excited
and then she ran up in the yard and said
oh there was a weird question at the end
will you be my girlfriend
i'd say why are you doing that for he's
good because he got gas with me i'll be
screaming why are you doing that don't
beat me out load up bill what are you
doing beating me up like that what do
you mean cause i'm trying to have a
reputation here quick man why are you
baiting me out in front of the man oh he
was a yacht for the man's as well oh he
was that's what i'm saying he's he's the
type of guy to be gassed for a whine
that's him that's harry and i loved i
loved his energy
i loved because he kept it he kept
he kept the same energy throughout the
whole show he was himself he was very
very very much in himself you know he's
very sincere so i love that about it
that's why i was like he's an authentic
guy very authentic tweeted me um
obie remember obi the guy from canada
obvi went through it bro he did go for
it but his intro real was like oh he's
funny i remember his intro he was saying
from canada he was in like the the
shower he's like doing all that
he says i don't i don't want to blow my
own trumpet but you know i'm a 10 out of
10 and he did his trumpets i'm like dude
he did that i was like yo bro bro
first of all first egg for ob
what accent is this that's how canadians
speak brother family they've got
they've got this american
mesh just twanging i think i don't
understand what you're saying
he leads me in one direction swerves me
actually what accent is this
um but bro when
i think i know what you want to say
ah this was okay this is actually not
over's fault oh this was my ick for kaz
because the black yap
yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes because
he jazz
jazz jazz
jazz jazz sorry not cows jazz
when he took her on the date yes
and then she was feeling it and she was
like feeling it feeling it feeling
feeling feeling feeling it feeling it
then they were like oh like what's going
on what's going on
and she just hit him with the he's too
short
i was so in my time he's not using my
tight he's just i want him taller
that hurt me fam that hurt me bro
there's literally nothing to do about
that
there's literally nothing he can do
about it and the the beating the jazz
that icked me
was his painting thing
if i was ob yeah i would have kicked her
right off the set i would have dashed
the paintball on her fam like entertain
the thing harry just got his face sat on
bro harry got his face out on and i'm
like you're doing this thing and you're
like ah
you're ruining the whole show
even patrick's getting a wine like
everyone's having fun oh why
i'm telling you now brother you know i
think before they did the patent thing
they did the positions thing the
breathing thing
on top of them i'm not i couldn't do on
that show i couldn't do it i literally
won't be able to appreciate brendan in
himself brendan the the sex guru or
relationship group he's he's annoying he
is a nick his entity isn't it he he is
brendan is the biggest ick i've ever
heard from when man said to nathan grab
your balls and grab your heart but at
the end of it don't smile nathan
it's as if he's wild crumble yeah yeah
he's flowing
[Laughter]
he didn't know what to do he realized
this guy's psychotic
[Music]
big man grab your balls grab your heart
and at the end of this don't smile at
the end of the breath don't smile no
it's not a joke that's what you're
saying you need to know by the end of
this it's not a joke fam
that whole thing was so yes the show is
not fake but that bit was so fake like
yeah he obviously just wanted to go back
to the villa to smash yeah so man was
saying everything any and everything to
go back he's like yeah i've got it
just a deeper emotion this daniella i've
known this about holly all along he said
i love holly i was like oh you're not
getting out of me you can threaten to
kick me out all you want you're not
getting out of me you're not getting it
out of me on national television i'm not
talking to national television
you're not getting it out on me big man
i'm not telling you i love you after
seven days i'm sorry no i'm sorry i
don't care how isolated we are i don't
care how close the nearest island is
you're not getting it from take me off
the show shout me when you're out
because i'm smashing
i'm not telling you i love you just to
go back next day yeah yeah bro
the one ache i had for nathan
was i've got it for nathan but the one
egg i had for nathan was when they were
when they got their watches
okay that's not another one the the only
thing as the first time i could i could
fully see it from a woman's perspective
okay because obviously you know when
they say that our women are just horny
as men etc etc yes yes
but when you're begging pom yes it's
icky bro yes and i've never seen that
from like a guy like i've never seen
from women's perspective before but fam
when they got their watches when they're
in the pool when when harry and bo were
on a date and him and holly on a date
and they were in the ball yes yes yes
they were chatting chatting vamp he was
this
every second
i don't think it works
was like yeah screen time she was trying
to connect and mum was like is it green
yet from like
when is it gonna turn green like lana
honestly i don't think my watch works
green green green magic cream when's it
green green come on green
she couldn't get a word in front without
being like green green
we spoke about jerry [ __ ] it up yeah
yeah yeah
oh fam
one
one ick for me
is bo beau
just her entity it's mainly her voice
fam sambo's voice that this is how i
like this is both for me right so
bo as an experience for me
is like i imagine them you know when
when they were waiting and they first
landed yes and they were by the table
would sip and drinks and then people
would walk in from a distance
yes i imagined like being a guy and
seeing beau from a distance i'm thinking
okay yeah yeah i'm like yo what's up i'm
james fam and then she speaks oh
[Applause]
big man
what is wrong with your voice i would
not give obi the time of day
he was here for her oh i'm so annoyed
because i thought she was gonna stir up
drama with nathan holly and that's what
i was here for that's why i was here i
was waiting for a scrap
[ __ ] that's what i was i all i wanted
was for holly to know the truth about
what nathan oh the fact that that never
came up pisses me off pissed me off how
he got away with that
and truth didn't
truth got nabbed immediately and made
the next morning i've told you from
nathan was the golden child of the whole
show he couldn't go wrong
he lost them 90 grand and just because
he got it back he was it was all okay
it was all okay from the fact
the fact when lana first sent them in
there
whether this is going to be the chest
the the test of chastity yeah in the
suite yeah and they lipped
i would have knocked down profile i
promise i'm not speaking to evident for
the rest of the show
how can you do that to us
she literally said
what was it 90 bags plus the lips
no it was 47 yeah yeah it was
um it was um
i think it totaled up to 40 sides it
totaled up to like
no no no no no because what was it
because it was 69 that whole thing was
69. there we go 69 bags yeah yeah no so
they lost
30 bags
because they bet on them true like they
bet on them should we trust them or not
and they all because of um patrick they
all decided to trust that they're not
gonna do anything so lana said if you
trust them it's gonna cost you 30 bags
if if you don't trust them or no
whatever you trust them or don't trust
them if you get it right 30 bags if you
get it wrong you lose 30 bags so then
they came back they lost the 30 bags
plus a 12 for lipstick yeah bro
bro i'm banging them out six bags per
lips
and you think you can you think after
that
after the robot donnie sent you into the
yard to not do anything yeah you think
you can do something twice
cost me 42 bags
and then come chat to me like with boys
afterwards and blah sorry guy i feel bad
you don't feel bad because the whole
reason you got sitting there in the
first place because you can't stop lips
in fam
the only
the only
um kudos i'll give him is the fact that
he stayed with one chick like as much as
he tried to deviate he stayed with holly
from the jump true but i don't think he
had much choice for him well he did he
had he did have brianna but he didn't
want that heat yes i think he didn't
have a choice because
no matt if he switches girls
it's not going to last because the drama
is it's gonna cause it's not worth it
and you can't bang them anyway that's
what i wanted oh of course what you all
want to hear for that's what we all
wanted [ __ ] i can't believe we got away
with that i can't it's not fair enough
yeah i've written everything for the
whole show it's not fair that you've got
to believe he got away with that bro it
does it's just oh i just remembered one
ic go on go and go when when were you
talking about jackson when jackson first
came in and it was the whole triangle
between jackson olga and izzy and they
were both chatting to jackson
olga didn't shut the [ __ ] up i want to
dash my drink in her face shut up
shut up bruh
she was saying yeah i play wrong but
yeah i did this yeah i did that blah
blah blah i'm building orphanages
i'll kick her in the pool
you're chatting [ __ ] brother get out my
face
fam izzy was just there like rawr
i can't even get edward in
and then when she went to go and tell
georgia and blah blah and georgia was
like oh did you manage to get a word he
was like thank you
thank you at least someone gets it
i couldn't i couldn't believe how much
olga spoke
and then just olga's in the interview
thing like did you see him spotting me
he's high-fiving him
high-fives shut up oh he's gonna pick me
blah blah blah he's gonna pick me he's
gonna pick me i've never seen a smile
turn to a frown so quick live it oh she
must have felt so ugly oh 100 felt so
ugly inside oh bro inside and out the
two ugliest moments of feeling in that
whole time was one
where and that moment patrick where
where um
no not even the patrick thing was the
algae thing that you just said and two
was when
um brianna got to choose someone to go
on the date
she said i've got chocolate boy in the
corner
but i'm gonna go with nathan i've got
chocolate boy but i wouldn't be myself
if i if i didn't go after what i wanted
something like that like that a man was
smiling like that
and then he sat by the pool and said i
hate being second place
i'm in second place
you're not i'm leaving after man said
he's a 10 out of 10. this is why you
can't hype yourself up too much before
you go
10 out of 10 and then one girl that you
fancy first said you're too short the
next girl you fancy said i like you but
my man who i've never spoken to i'm
choosing him
yo you've given me everything
but nah my man get me off the show i'm
looking dead in the camera
mockumentary style however it's called
get me off the show
cut the whole thing get me off the show
i'm taking the thing off and i'm taking
the thing off get me off the show
you've humiliated me time and time again
i've been here 48 hours and you won't
stop humiliating me man said
international tv that's sweetened me i
don't know why
fam
this is an international broadcasting
network and you just stay humiliating
mugging me off i'll never recover
because after this you're sending me
back into the streets with no money
and you expect me to just live my life
man kept on talking about college i
could use this i'd use this money for
quite sharp you're not gonna win you're
not gonna win bro
oh
fam i think that's enough too out to
handle that is i think that is enough to
handle sorry if you one don't watch the
show i don't care about the show but
you're gonna have to watch the show now
you're gonna have to we do you have to
watch your channel it's unfortunate but
you're gonna have to jesus man um that
was funny but yeah just real quick i've
got a funny topic hit me
so the other day i saw
fam remember when i said to you
facebook's got gold yeah you have fans
found facebook still got some gold in
there deep in the trenches it's got some
gold so i saw i saw um a little
threading the other day which was um
what can you say um during sex
but also about the family dinner
oh
that sounds juicy fam that sounds juicy
let me just give you a taste that sounds
juicy
here's the promise what can you say
during sex but can't uh but no what can
you say during sex but also at a family
dinner okay yeah
first one i'm craving the good stuff
here
bro yep well played solid played
bro oh god i i'm gonna have to say them
the way i read them i know what you mean
please don't invite uncle joe again
please don't invite uncle joe again
no
fam
that bird was a bit dry
bro
some of them are jokes
i'm not putting that in my mouth
fair fam
someone put i don't want to be here
i don't want to be here
i can't imagine what yeah i'd say that
bro that's jokes found this one
it's a mummy thing
stop playing with it and just eat it
i could i could never be in a sexual
confrontation or sexual act and then
yeah tell me stop playing with it just
[ __ ] eat it stop playing over just
eating i'll be so embarrassed
i'll feel so small playing with it just
eat it i feel so small i'd feel small
but i'd be kind of turned on turn up
i'll also be thinking what the [ __ ] am i
doing what are you doing what am i doing
but yeah fam i'll be turned on stop play
with it just [ __ ] eat it oh
and some weird little reverse sub
subdominating i'll be a little bit like
yeah
yes ma'am all right say list yes ma'am
oh jesus
yum tastes just like daddy's
yum tastes just like daddy's
yo
imagine someone saying that yo
i don't care if we are at the dinner
table
i don't care if we had to say dinner
table
yum just says just like daddy's that's
just
even if we are a completely platonic
dinner table don't say things like that
fam
let me read one thing because you said
um daddy's assignment i've got
a tweet
that
reminded me oh so sorry g i have to find
it
oh [ __ ] you know where is it where is it
where is it
that's annoying
oh that's annoying i'll find a layer but
continue go on i think i've only got one
more anyway okay yeah it's just like
daddy's
oh finally it looked better than it
tasted
oh
that's very pink that is a bit peak gee
that is very people that's a that's a
good interesting that's a good threat
that's a really good threat you know
what made me interesting as well
facebook's got gold but people just
aren't here for facebook like of course
not the people the people who are on
facebook
like
there's a reason they're on facebook
okay because like if you saw that on
twitter yeah there'd be hate in there
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah miles and miles
of people of course of course of course
of course
some of these comments were so dead i
see some of the majority were so dead
and you think this this is why this is
on facebook because twitter would be
coming with fire dirt fire fire
fire for this dirt fire but yeah you had
a video for me in it
let's do the video and wrap up yeah oh
my god uh it is on twitter
right it's i don't even know where this
video is from i saw it died
and i should have loses
it's nothing
miss howard what are you thinking
she lied and i should have known better
when i seen her hair i got a feeling you
were worried weren't you i mean nine
thousand dollars i wasn't worried
because
thank you
that can't run
it's the funniest thing bro
out of context it's just tweeting i was
like ah twitter's the funniest place on
earth twitter twitter twitter actually
is the funny funniest place on earth
like how has she left her yard like that
bro that's not on it's not fair speaking
of oh actually senator teller tell us
i'll tell you before we finish you did
say it actually and i want to do it now
um
you said
um you've got it that people keep
sending you yes
did you see the one the other day that
was going around in terms of
did you see the other day that was like
that i don't even try it absolutely
you're waiting
like this did you see that another day
that was like you must have seen it
i want to get do you know sometimes yeah
when i when i need to say something i
get vexed because i'm worried
that i'm going to laugh and not get it
out so i have to compose myself so i
can't look at you
did you see the one that's like
your mcm tries to crack jokes with the
barber and all he replies with is keep
your head still
i didn't see that one brother
nah oh my god the one i did see though
similar very similar because it was a
barber thing she said something along
the lines of i've got on my phone
my ache is when he's at the barbers and
he has to wear that wizard cape tight
around his neck also when he wears
skinny jeans men who wear skinny jeans
with their balls dangling with no air
it's dude that end that end it was
stupid but she was talking about the the
[ __ ] the [ __ ] cape thing [ __ ]
cases we said bro we have no choice
literally we have no choice what do you
want me to do about it what do you want
me to do i have no choice in the matter
that's literally like i told you that
time where i need got the parking ticket
a man left the cape on me and i
literally had some half head fam half
head he literally done that outside no
fade i had afro on top no skin around
the sides no problem wizard cape tissue
around my neck and literally had to run
out and the tingles just fling yeah
nah how someone didn't drop kick me i
don't know bro i would have yanked the
ting off and said you have to wrap
another one that one's long gone
that one is long gone bro
bro oh that's too funny i was i've never
been so humiliated and the peer pressure
that
all the patrons of the shop put on me to
move my car i was willing to to firm the
ticket
and all of them were like now just go
and move your [ __ ] car and they're
making me feel like an [ __ ] yeah
let's just move your car big man we'll
wait i'm in the chair i'm in the chair
and they're like it's fine move your
[ __ ] car it's not fine look at my
hair top [ __ ] my head top and that's
the thing i was too embarrassed at that
time to be like i'm not going out like
this yeah
so finish my hair i'm not going out like
this
[ __ ] that's jared yeah but jokes at the
same time it was very jokes but um
yeah man we've been chatting your era
for long enough guys that's going to
wrap it up um jump into too hot to
handle enjoy yourself let us know what
you think i've we've already had a few
messages to buy actually asking if we've
seen it now you know there you go
guys if you want to catch up on uh some
more episodes coming thursday
patreon.com forward slash shits and gigs
as always guys please church the thing
in the comments like the video speaking
of chirps sorry i know we're ending the
show
um i was looking on the comments or
maybe the last monday's video video the
monday before someone commented chirps
that's what they keep literally just
church question mark that's what i said
to you double week bro
that's what i keep doing and fam you
know what yeah the guys have been
lagging now it's more girls girls yeah
yeah girls are flying the flag they're
throwing their thing out right now it
was man
and then the girls are just bang bang
bang chaps
they're ready for it they're ready
mandem reply yeah please reply
because they want it they're on it yeah
they're bang on it bro gang all right
guys
love love
[Music]